the average NBA team is worth
$3.85 billion this year 35% more than a
year ago here are the top five highest
valued NBA teams in fifth place are the
Los Angeles Clippers the Clippers next
season are moving into a new $1.2
billion Arena which will provide a
significant boost to the team's
Revenue the fourth highest valued NBA
team are the Boston Celtics the Celtics
have an extremely loyal fan base and for
that reason charge one of the highest
ticket prices in the NBA the third most
valuable team in the NBA are the Los
Angeles Lakers the Lakers have the
richest cable TV deal in the league the
team gets $3.2 billion in rights fees
over 20 years the second most valuable
team in the NBA are the New York Knicks
despite not winning very often on the
hardwood the Knicks generated $169
million in operating income last season
the most in the NBA and taking the top
spot in the NBA as the League's most
valuable team are the Golden State
Warriors who have won four titles over
the past nine years the Warriors play in
the chase Center the NBA's most
lucrative Arena the Warriors generated
$765 million in Revenue last season 48%
more than any other
[Music]
team